in Britain it is decision time after
years of fierce debate members of
parliament are holding a rare Saturday
meeting to consider a crucial vote on
brexit the House of Commons is
discussing whether to adopt the revised
deal reached earlier this week between
Prime Minister Boris Johnson and the
European Union
Ian Lee is in London with the latest
Ian's good morning a good morning it
could be do or die for Prime Minister
Boris Johnson today as they vote on his
brexit deal with the European Union this
is the first time Parliament has sat on
a Saturday since 1982 during the
Falklands War now speaking with people
here a lot of them are not only against
the Prime Minister's brexit deal but
against brexit in general they want to
see the UK remain with the European
Union
it's a spasm right wing reaction and as
a citizen of Europe and a citizen of the
future I'd like to stay in the EU we
need to remember though that this is
just a snapshot of what's going on in
the UK right now there are other places
that not only support the Prime
Minister's brexit deal but they want to
see the UK leave the European Union I
think a lot of people though were
surprised that the Prime Minister was
able to get a deal but it is going to
come down to Parliament and that magic
number is 320 he's going to need to
convince rebel members of parliament
within his own party as well as
opposition Labour Party members to get
on board for this the past but if this
isn't complicated enough there could be
a curveball that postpones the vote
until Monday but the clock is ticking
they have 12 days to either ask for an
extension or get a deal as the brexit
deadline is Halloween October 31st for
CBS this morning Saturday Ian Lee in
London